Ya saben qué es no mirar a nadie en el metro,
pero supongo que él sí que me vio.
Creo que nos miraba a todos nosotros,
mientras su mano rondaba el interruptor de la detonación.
A menudo me he preguntado: ¿En qué estaría pensando?
Especialmente en esos segundos finales.
Sé que no era personal.
No se dispuso a matarme o mutilarme a mí, Gill Hicks.
Quiero decir, él no me conocía.
No.
En cambio, me colocó
una etiqueta injustificada y no deseada.
Me había convertido en el enemigo.
Para él, yo era el "otro",
el "ellos" en lugar de "nosotros".
La etiqueta de "enemigo", le permitió deshumanizarnos.
Esto le permitió apretar ese botón.
Y él no era selectivo.
Acabó con 26 preciosas vidas solo en mi vagón
y yo casi fui una de ellas.
En el tiempo necesario para tomar aliento,
nos sumergimos en una oscuridad tan inmensa
que era casi tangible.
Lo que imagino que debe ser vadear por alquitrán.
Nosotros no sabíamos que éramos el enemigo.
Estábamos en un grupo de pasajeros que, minutos antes,
había seguido las reglas de comportamiento en el metro:
no hay contacto visual directo,
no se habla
absolutamente, ninguna conversación.
Pero al desaparecer la oscuridad,
procurábamos llegarnos.
Nos ayudábamos entre sí.
Estábamos diciendo nuestros nombres,
un poco como pasar la lista,
en espera de respuestas.
"Soy Gill. Estoy aquí.
Estoy viva.
Bien."
"Soy Gill.
Aquí.
Viva.
Bien."
No conocía a Alison.
Pero oía sus señales cada pocos minutos.
No conocía a Richard.
Pero me importaba que él sobreviviera.
Todo lo que compartí con ellos
fue mi nombre.
Ellos no sabían
que yo era jefa del departamento en el Consejo de Diseño.
Y aquí está mi amado maletín,
También rescatado esa mañana.
Ellos no sabían que publiqué revistas de arquitectura y diseño,
que era miembro de la Royal Society of Arts,
que vestía de negro,
lo que aún hago,
que fumaba puritos.
Ahora ya no fumo más.
Bebía ginebra y miraba TED Talks,
por supuesto, sin imaginar que un día iba a estar yo aquí,
manteniendo el equilibrio sobre mis piernas protésicas
dando una charla.
Yo era una mujer australiana joven haciendo cosas extraordinarias en Londres.
Y no estaba preparada para poner fin a todo eso.
Estaba tan decidida a sobrevivir
que con mi pañuelo até torniquetes en la parte superior de mis piernas,
y tapo todo y todos salen,
para enfocar, para escucharme a mí misma,
guiarme por el instinto.
Bajé la tasa de respiración.
Elevé mis muslos.
Me mantuve en posición vertical
y luché contra el impulso de cerrar los ojos.
Me aferré durante casi una hora,
una hora contemplando la totalidad de mi vida
hasta ese momento.
Tal vez debería haber hecho más.
Tal vez podría haber vivido más, visto más.
Tal vez debería haber ido a correr, bailar, hacer yoga.
Pero mi prioridad y mi enfoque siempre fue mi trabajo.
Yo vivía para trabajar.
Quién era yo en mi tarjeta de visita
me importaba.
Pero no importaba en ese túnel.
En el momento en que sentí ese primer contacto
de uno de mis rescatadores,
yo fui incapaz de hablar,
incapaz de decir siquiera una palabra pequeña, como "Gill".
Les entregué mi cuerpo a ellos.
Había hecho todo lo posible,
y ahora estaba en sus manos.
Entendí
quién y lo que la humanidad realmente es,
cuando vi por primera vez la marca de identificación
que me dieron cuando me admitieron en el hospital.
Y ponía:
"Desconocido probablemente mujer."
Desconocido probablemente mujer.
Esas tres palabras eran mi regalo.
Lo que me dijeron muy claramente
era que mi vida estaba a salvo,
simplemente por ser un ser humano.
Diferencia de ningún tipo marcaron una diferencia
en las medidas extraordinarias que prepararon los equipos de rescate
para salvar mi vida,
para salvar tantas vidas desconocidas como pudieron,
y poniendo sus propias vidas en peligro.
Para ellos, no importaba si yo era rica o pobre,
el color de mi piel,
si era hombre o mujer,
mi orientación sexual,
a quién voté,
si tenía educación,
si tenía confesión o si carecía de fe alguna.
Nada importaba
aparte de ser una preciosa vida humana.
Me veo como un hecho vivo.
Yo soy una prueba
de que el amor incondicional y el respeto no sólo pueden salvar,
sino que pueden transformar vidas.
Aquí hay una imagen maravillosa de uno de mis rescatadores, Andy, y yo
tomada el año pasado.
Diez años después del suceso,
y aquí estamos, abrazados.
A lo largo de todo el caos,
mi mano estaba agarrada con fuerza.
Mi cara acariciada suavemente.
¿Qué sentí?
Me sentía querida.
Lo que me blinda contra el odio y la retribución,
lo que me ha dado el valor de decir:
esto termina conmigo
es amor.
Fui amada.
Creo que el potencial para un cambio positivo generalizado
es absolutamente enorme
porque sé de lo que somos capaces.
Sé lo hermoso de la humanidad.
Así que esto me deja con algunas cosas bastante grandes para reflexionar
y algunas preguntas para todos a tener en cuenta:
¿No es lo que nos une mucho más que lo que nos puede separar?
¿Tiene que pasar una tragedia o un desastre
para que nos sintamos profundamente conectados como una sola especie,
como seres humanos?
¿Y cuándo abrazaremos la sabiduría de nuestra era
elevándose por encima de la simple tolerancia
y pasando a aceptar
a todos los que son sólo una etiqueta hasta que los conocemos?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)